exciting news around the launch of ibm
cloud satellite
and the open beta of ansible actions in
ibm cloud schematics
all on this episode of ibm cloud now
what's up y'all my name is ian and i am
back to bring you the latest and
greatest news and announcements from ibm
cloud
to start things off i am thrilled to
announce a significant milestone in the
expansion of our hybrid cloud
capabilities with a new offering called
ibm cloud satellite
ibm cloud satellite makes it possible
for you to build faster securely
anywhere
you can now deploy ibm cloud services
securely in any environment
public cloud private cloud on premises
or at the edge
since satellite operates as a
distributed cloud environment
it extends the same security inherent
within ibm cloud
no matter where data is being collected
processed or shared
with ibm cloud satellite you can run
workloads where it makes the most sense
because ibm cloud is architected with an
open source kubernetes foundation
for greater portability to the satellite
locations
you'll have access to a rich catalog of
cloud services and enjoy simplified
service availability and control
this means a single dashboard common
identity and access management policies
and centralized observability across all
your satellite locations
this will help you achieve end-to-end
security where data and workloads reside
for all the exciting details on the
launch of ibm cloud satellite
see the link in the description of this
video in keeping with the satellite
theme
ibm is also extending watson anywhere
making it possible to bring ai workloads
to your data using ibm cloud pack for
data as a service with ibm cloud
satellite
you can eliminate the need to move data
around or copy from other public clouds
to get insights
data science teams can efficiently build
machine learning models in the cloud
and then run the models in the same
cloud region where your data is stored
this means a completely seamless data
analytics experience
as a result businesses can see
significant performance improvements
when ai workloads are co-located with
data
maintain data sovereignty and compliance
as data remains in-country
leverage the best talent wherever they
are and avoid data egress costs
since data doesn't need to be
transferred out of the public cloud
for more info on ibm cloud pack for data
as a service with ibm cloud satellite
check out the blog i've got link below
okay
to close out this episode i want to let
you know about the open beta of ansible
actions in ibm cloud schematics
ansible is an open source software
provisioning
configuration management and application
deployment tool
that enables infrastructure as code
schematics
enables you to import ansible playbooks
define input configuration
and control the lifecycle of ansible
automation
schematic supports two primary
approaches to automation
workspaces which are terraform-based and
actions which are ansible-based
terraform is primarily used for
provisioning and ansible excels at
configuration management
and application deployment put them
together terraform and ansible are a
perfect match for end-to-end
infrastructure automation
to get started with the open beta of
ansible actions and schematics
hit the link below thanks so much for
joining me today for this episode of ibm
cloud now
if you're interested in learning more
about the topics i've covered make sure
you explore the links in the description
of this video
and again please don't forget to
subscribe to our channel to stay up to
date on what's going on in the cloud
now
you